reject nation
we're gonna watch four i count four
teaser trailers for
let there be car nudge today i'm very
very excited about this movie even
though it's only 20 minutes long
according to the newly released runtime
it's a short film it's a short film and
it's all in the trailer
just combine them and that's pretty much
the film it was supposed to only be like
86 minutes but we got about two minutes
here of four teaser trailers combined
into one from the movie channel
moviegasm let's just play them all back
to back and enjoy our little ride here
today if you end up enjoying this video
please hit that like button it always
helps us out on the algorithm subscribe
click that bell to get notified when our
review is up for venomotherby corners
because you best bet we are going to
watch that and talk about it
you are a cancer to everyone who ever
loved you
oh yeah
is
cool
hoo
the chocolate delivery hasn't arrived
yet i am happy to eat mrs jackson no no
you cannot eat mrs chen what nothing
exclusively movie
hey mrs chen the chocolate delivery
hasn't arrived yet no i am happy to eat
it
you cannot eat mrs chen what nothing
i am a predator
those two need some serious couples
counseling
[Music]
exciting time to be a spider-man fan
exciting time to be
a venom fan i
can't say
much
i really can't i'm gonna be the end of
that to protect
some people and to not ruin
friendships i'll say the positive thing
though is that i've heard that the
action for sure is much better than the
first venom movie okay i'll leave it at
that you can see what's going on
see the characters i've been wanting to
see on screen for so long yeah man the
runtime is something that is a bit
concerning to me like that does sound i
think it like clocks in at like 90
minutes or something like that it's like
they they made it like what do we need
to hit to be to be considered a movie
because from the venom comic books and
the carnage comics there's so much story
to mine there i don't know how you'd be
pressed to run out of story ideas yeah
something to flush this out or let it
breathe so how it wouldn't be a struggle
to keep a movie like this under 90
minutes or an hour and 45 years or
something like that yeah i've been
having a lot of faith in it the thing is
i saw john campbeau's video where he did
talk extensively about how we shouldn't
be so worried about that fact because
there's some great movies that are like
90 minutes or some terrible movies under
three hours that over say it's welcome
and while i respect that argument and
that discussion i i don't think it's
unreasonable to be a tad bit concerned
about it depending on what you want from
this like if i want this movie to be
improved upon from the first one even
though we are two people who did come
out and go you know it was really fun it
was really enjoyable it's not great but
if you look at it it's like a fun 90s
movie it does work having that sort of
mindset around it and what it was like
cheesy fun and enjoyable did really
click it's just like the trailers have
been so solid to me as of late yeah like
it looks like the comedy's really solid
and then when you watch the trailers the
main appeal of it is the action and the
violence that you're seeing on display
and to know that that's gonna be better
and then the trailers strongly represent
that obviously that's something that i
do think is great yeah even like looking
at the bits here they just go to further
enhance all the things that i'm already
excited for yeah absolutely you know but
yeah john yeah i thought thoughts on on
life
yeah i'm torn on the the whole run time
thing because partly to me like looking
at all these different tv spots trailers
etc it seems like they are drawing from
a pretty limited range of moments even
though we did even get a couple new
shots here part of me thinks that maybe
yeah the runtime could just be
indicative of it and i don't want to say
like contained in a way to make it seem
like oh it's going to feel small or
something but maybe it'll be a more
contained movie i feel like a lot of
superhero super anti-hero movies reach
for a lot and there are a lot of plot
points and easter eggs and characters
and things to touch upon and make them
bloated yeah and so maybe i guess the
best thing i could hope for is perhaps
this movie will just hone in on cletus
cassidy and eddie brock and have a
little bit going on with michelle
williams just tight thriller yeah tight
thriller with the carnage that you want
and yeah be no more or less than it
needs to be and after the first movie i
mean they had clearly something that
worked and some stuff that maybe didn't
work as well so maybe they wanted to
come back this time and yeah go lean
mean and make sure the important things
are checked off and that's my hope
because this looks just as fun as the
first well i'll say though is what
strikes me as a little bit odd when i
when i think about the casting here it
really dawned on me watching these
t-shirts is it looks like tom hardy's
having a lot of fun as eddie brock
specifically and woody harrelson's
taking himself a little more serious
yeah i always thought it'd be a little
different yeah that if he flipped it
yeah like this would be like the time
for eddie to really take things
seriously yeah like i'm fighting like
this horrible criminal but every scene
we see him in he just seems like on edge
yeah he's having fun with being on it
yeah yeah really enjoy that on edge but
also like quirky awkward guy energy that
he brings to eddie bro but i'm looking
forward to it man of course i would want
like the cleanest cassidy sinister tones
i'd like this to be rated r it's not
going to be i'm not surprised by that if
anything i'm way more surprised by the
run time than i am the
npa rating but we'll see man i'm still
looking forward to it and we'll give our
honest thoughts right when we come out
of the theater but guys what do you
think about everything we've been
getting for venom let there be carnage
do you want to see tom hardy's venom
versus tom holland spider-man leave your
thoughts down below
let's do a pic
eric horseman eric my guy i think if
there's one person out there who would
have a great relationship with a
symbiote it would be you dude you would
totally embrace
annihilating people in the most sinister
gleeful way i can only imagine imagine
just how much you would enjoy if you've
ever if anyone has ever gotten to know
eric horseman you would think greg's
just making another stupid sarcastic
patron of the day shout out not the case
at all not at all this dude
would undoubtedly enjoy bonding with the
semiod do whatever he can to get rid of
certain groups of people he really does
not like and he would absolutely embrace
it so eric
if there's one thing i can say is that
if there's anyone here who i hope
can attach himself to a symbiote if they
ever do become real i hope you're the
lucky candidate out there
thank you for being you say hi to all
the dead people
[Music]